j'ai eu accès avec m florent
l'intégralité des éléments du dossier
d'instruction et bien évidemment le
rapport d'autopsié mais elle voit mesure
de dire comment elle est morte alors je
suis tenu au secret de l'instruction je
vous dirais simplement que j'ai trouvé
un rapport de top 6 comme l'avait dit
procureur de la république initialement
totalement concluants et donc sur ce
rapport d'autopsié unique et concluant
j'ai pu donner à johnattan qui ont été
en demande les causes précises dans
lesquelles son épouse a été tuée lorsque
la procureure avait dit à l'époque c'est
qu'elle était probablement un décédé
suite à une assise c'est confirmé je dis
simplement que le procureur de la
république à l'époque avait fait des
déclarations sérieuses sur un rapport de
topsy qui me semble clair et que je ne
vois pas en l'état ce qui viendrait
modifier les conclusions de ce rapport
de tufts alex elle a été violée alors
c'est pareil nous avions là aussi des
déclarations autour je crois d'une
source proche de l'enquêté qui faisait
savoir qu'il n'y avait pas eu d'atteinte
à caractère sexuel je ne peux pas vous
dire ce que j'ai trouvé dans le dossier
mais toujours est il que j'ai pu donner
des éléments au mari d'alexia
et voilà mon après la source qui avait
été cité mettez une source fiable
la lfp avait relayé cette information je
reste tenu au secret de l'instruction
mais je pense qu'il serait peut-être
utile que nous procure de la république
s'exprime sur cette partie alors vous
avez eu accès au dossier ou photos du
site
est ce qu'il ya des éléments concluant
donc vous avez connaissance des indices
importants fort alors c'est pareil sur
les communications on avait un a priori
sur le dossier avec m flore on à
consulter l'intégralité du dossier les
photographies la zone de découverte du
corps d'annexion
ça confirme les photographies qu'on a vu
effectivement prises au moment de la
découverte confirme tout à fait là aussi
les déclarations du parquet selon
lesquelles on l'a retrouvé des indices
en nombre important
ces indices en nombre important vous
permettre d investigation elle-même
importantes et notamment les
investigations techniques scientifiques
et notamment des prélèvements adn est ce
qu on a une idée
du moment où elle est morte la datation
alors oui on a une idée aujourd'hui
assez précise
je trouve même très précise du moment où
alex est décédé je peux pas la révéler
mais en tout cas on a eu cette
information qui est arrivé très
récemment au dossier
vous avez donc mis votre client au
courant de tous ces éléments de
l'intégralité il est au courant de tout
y compris de ce que je n'ai pas le droit
de vous dire la question de savoir s'il
ya eu des atteintes sexuelles je lui ai
répondu la question de savoir à quel
moment à peu près elle était décédée
je lui ai répondu aussi sur ce point là
la question de savoir s'il ya eu des
coups pas le coup je lui ai répondu sur
tous les points que je ne peux pas
développer avec foule lui a eu comme ses
parents d'ailleurs l'intégralité des
réponses qu'on pouvait leur rapporter
qui était très satisfaisante en terme de
réponse je dis pas que humainement
parlant pour eux il y avait une
quelconque satisfaction que je vais vous
demander comment est-ce qu'il a réagi
lui qui a fait qui a été la cible d'un
déchaînement sur les réseaux sociaux par
rapport à son application ou pas dans la
disparition et le décès de sa femme
je dirais que certaines réponses y ont
apporté un léger soulagement
j'utiliserai le terme léger parce que ça
reste un garçon très fragile très
blessée très meurtrie
et je n'irai pas à dire que il a eu
satisfaction de l'entretien qu'on a pu
avoir par rapport à ça et ça reste un
kir et qui est toujours je trouve en
grande détresse psychologique parce que
vous dites qu'il ya des indices
concluant qui ouvre la porte à des
investigations techniques poussées
notamment des recherches d'adr est ce
qu'on aura une idée assez rapide de la
suite ce qui aura des perquisitions de
la garde à vue est ce que vous m'appelez
comme votre confrère que ce dossier sera
dénouer assez rapidement par expérience
que m florent lorsqu'on a consulté le
dossier
on était tous les deux à un moment et
c'est ce qu'on s'est dit avant la fin
décembre avant les fêtes
à mon sens à notre sens on aura la
solution de cette affaire c'est une
intime conviction c'est une façon de
mettre la pression
alors c'est pas du tout une façon m
d'abord c'est un sentiment
deuxièmement aucune enquête n'est termes
éthiques on sait des choses sur les
différents intervenants de façon directe
ou indirecte
ce n'est pas que mon sentiment c'est que
effectivement on sent que l'anc est
arrivé à son terme et que l'échéance se
serait plutôt d'ici la fin décembre
en tout cas un petit peu avant les fêtes
parce que les investigations techniques
sont terminées parce qu'on sent toujours
en cours alors nous n'avons plus accès à
ces informations là puisqu'elle ne sont
pas revenus au dossier d'instruction
en principe la grande partie des
investigations techniques a dû revenir
au procureur de la république et aussi
au service de la section de recherche
notamment pour la plus grosse partie des
prélèvements adn
parce qu'on est dans une enquête
criminelle qui nécessite un travail
d'urgence
donc je pense qu'ils ont une grande
partie peut-être l'intégralité laissez
pas évident mais ça ne devrait pas
tarder des retours des investigations
sur les pièces à conviction et sur les
indices bien évidemment on a trouvé sur
la scène de crime
lorsque vous il ya des indices concluant
donc qui vont déboucher sur des examens
techniques encore plus douce et on
s'étonne en fait depuis début de ce
dossier à vous entendre vous et votre
collègue dire que ya des éléments
concluant qu'on va arriver à une fin
plutôt rapide par rapport à ce genre de
dossier
pourquoi il n'y a pas eu encore de
perquisitions de garde à vue je pense
que la section de recherches qui c'est
un travail en profondeur ne veut pas se
tromper c'est mon sentiment qu'ils
veulent une interpellation et pas deux
et qui veulent interpeller la bonne
personne là où les bonnes personnes
mais en tout cas je pense que leur grand
souci c'est de ne pas faire d'erreur
toute erreur dans ce type d'affaires et
toute erreur d'interpellations pour
l'avoir déjà connus c'est toujours
dramatique pour la personne qui n'est
pas impliqué au bout du compte et qui se
retrouve placé en garde à vue et livré
au jugement populaire
donc je pense que c'est vraiment le
souci de cibler très précisément le plus
précisément possible avec le moins
d'erreurs possible la personne qui peut
être impliqués et de cause à effet la
personne qui serait l'auteur
je pense que le souci d'aider service
des enquêtes et de la section de
recherches est un c'est ce souci là qui
est un souci qui est un souci de qualité
d' enquête qui est un souci de sécurité
aussi pour les personnes qui pourraient
être interpellés parce que vous pourrez
interpellé beaucoup de gens ont fait
dans une affaire comme celle là mais
à mon sens ils veulent interpeller
l'auteur est pas faire d'erreurs et je
pense qu'ils ont raison on a eu
l'occasion de parler des rumeurs dont a
fait l'objet votre votre client vous qui
avez vu donc accès au dossier qui avait
pu vous entretenir avec lui maintenant
plusieurs fois j'imagine
est ce que vous avez fait la lumière sur
ces dernières heures sont la libye
notamment puisque c'est ce qui faisait
un peu défaut mais qui fait que la
rumeur s'est déchaîné écoutez je ne les
jamais interrogé je vais être franc avec
vous depuis que je les rencontre et j'ai
trouvé un garçon désarmant en pleine
détresse et une profonde gentillesse
je n'ai pas interroger un mari victime
de la mort de son épouse c'est pas mon
travail c'est sans objet mais comme vous
je j'entends et je regarde les choses et
j'ai vu notamment
ça ne vient pas de moi mais qui étaient
parues dans la presse
une information sur laquelle johnatan
avait rencontré son employeur notamment
à 10h45 le samedi matin et que son
employeur et précisé qu'il était
souriant comme d'habitude et qui avait
rien de spécial voilà c'est pas un
élément anodin si vous voulez pour moi
qui connais notamment l'heure
approximative du des cdo d'alexia ça
conforte simplement mon sentiment que ce
garçon est une victime dans ce dossier
que il est la victime de la mort de son
épouse
donc il est l'occasion pour confirmer
qu'il a bien vu sa femme partir vous
alentours 9h15 9h30 ce samedi matin il
n'a je voulais dit je ne les interrogé
sur rien on n'interroge pas une personne
qui est victime dans une affaire de
cette nature là on interroge une
personne qui est soupçonnée
je n'ai pas interroger de natal il est
soupçonné de rien